[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today quantum field theory
unlike a marble which has a definite
position
at the microscopic scale a particle does
not really have a position
its presence is distributed throughout
space with more or less probability
this description of particles as waves
of probability
is called quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics allows us to describe
the evolution of a particle
over time
however this description as effective as
it is
fails to take into account two
considerations
firstly quantum mechanics cannot
describe situations where the number of
particles
varies over time however in nature we
often observe that particles can appear
or disappear
like when a photon gets absorbed by an
electron in an atom
secondly quantum mechanics treats each
particle independently
however within a family of particles
such as electrons
all exhibit the same properties and
behaviors
how is it that an electron coming from
the far reaches of the cosmos
has exactly the same mass or charge as
an electron in an apple
to answer this question we will have to
build a new mathematical framework
a more general description that
reconciles quantum mechanics with
special relativity
we will construct the most successful
framework available for describing the
microscopic world
in this video we build together quantum
field theory
to begin with let's start with an empty
universe
relativity teaches us that the fabric of
the universe is space-time
to simplify we will represent only two
dimensions of space
as well as the dimension of time
we now want to fill our universe with
content mata
we saw previously that all particles of
the same type
for example all electrons appear
perfectly identical
as if they were only local
manifestations of a single
underlying object which would fill the
whole universe
a field to add content to our universe
we will therefore start by adding a
field
[Music]
in mathematics a field is like a fluid
which fills all space time
each point of which is populated by a
mathematical object
it can be a field of numbers vectors
or other more exotic objects
that said special relativity imposes
some restrictions
it forces us to respect certain
symmetries which correspond to the
geometry of space-time
symmetries of translation rotation
or changing frame of reference
[Music]
these symmetries are only respected by
certain mathematical objects
and we can classify them with a
parameter spin
the simplest objects that we can use are
numbers
we give them spin zero because when we
rotate space around a number
it does not vary
vectors on the other hand indicate a
direction in space
their appearance depends on the
orientation in which they are observed
we assign them spin one because when we
rotate space by a full turn
a vector also describes a full turn
finally relativity also allows other
more exotic objects
and in particular spinners which have
spin one half
you have to make two turns around a
spinner for it to come back to its
initial state
[Music]
all these mathematical objects seem very
abstract
and some are difficult to understand but
technically they all obey the symmetries
of relativity
and are therefore potential candidates
with which we could fill our universe
[Music]
in addition to imposing the types of
objects that are allowed
space-time symmetries also set
restrictions on the way
objects behave inside the field
each symmetry forces the field to
respect the conservation of certain
quantity
over time to obey relativity
our field must respect the conservation
of energy
momentum angular momentum
and velocity of the centre of mass
moreover the mathematical objects
themselves can contain symmetries of
their own
if we decide to form a field with
complex numbers for example
they exhibit an internal symmetry which
implies the conservation of another
quantity over time
related to the very nature of complex
numbers
the electric charge
[Music]
at this stage we have a space time which
we have filled with a field
which satisfies all the restrictions
imposed by special relativity
but our goal is to describe the
microscopic world
so it's time to turn our field into a
quantum field
[Music]
in quantum mechanics to transform a
classical object into a quantum object
we allowed it to adopt several positions
at the same time
with more or less probability
[Music]
similarly to transform a classical field
into a quantum field
we allow it to adopt several
configurations
multiple ways it can evolve with more or
less importance
[Music]
over time our field evolves as a
superposition
of all possible scenarios
transitioning from a classical field to
a quantum field
results in a very interesting property
just like an electron in atom has
well-defined energy levels
[Music]
a quantum field also has energy levels
it can only contain an integer number of
disturbances
quanta of energy that can appear or
disappear
these are particles
much like a wave on the surface of water
a particle is simply a disturbance which
propagates within the field
[Music]
a quantum field is also agitated by
fluctuations
which keep popping in and out of
existence these are called virtual
particles
these virtual particles exist only very
briefly
so that it is strictly impossible to
observe them
[Music]
step by step our model universe is
getting closer to reality
we now describe a space-time filled with
a quantum field
inside which move disturbances particles
in a soup of fluctuations virtual
particles
in our universe several fields coexist
and constitute different families of
particles
some are vector fields spin 1 and the
particles they contain
are photons z and w bosons and gluons
others are fields of spinners spin one
half
they are the fermions that make up
matter quarks
electrons muons tau particles and
neutrinos
finally there is a field of spin zero
the higgs field
among all these fields most have
internal symmetries
which provide them with quantities that
are conserved over time
charges which distinguish their
particles between several versions
we saw previously that fields formed
with complex numbers
have asymmetry which gives them their
electric charge
this symmetry allows us to distinguish
two versions of the particles
one with positive charge the other with
negative charge
this is anti-matter in a way
the anti-particle is the complex
conjugate
of the ordinary particle
other fields also have more exotic
symmetries
the quark fields for example exhibit a
symmetry which assigns them another
charge
the colour charge which must also be
conserved over time
and that allows us to separate quarks
into three versions
red green and blue
the set of all these fields that make up
the content of our universe
is the standard model of particle
physics
to this day this is the most successful
description of our universe on the
microscopic scale
[Music]
our model universe now contains the same
particles as our real universe
however it still isn't realistic indeed
the symmetries of space time
force all particles to move in straight
lines forever
independently one from the other
to finally complete our model all we
have to do is add one more fundamental
ingredient
we need to allow these fields to
interact with each other
[Music]
to understand let's focus on one of the
simplest interactions
between the photon field and the
electron field
we will allow an electron to emit or
absorb a virtual photon
and vice versa allowing only this simple
interaction will have drastic
consequences
for instance in the following situation
we start with two electrons motionless
over time the two electrons progress
towards the future
at first one might think that the two
electrons remain motionless indefinitely
but that would be forgetting that our
electrons are constantly moving through
the photon field
with which we allowed them to interact
[Music]
we saw that a quantum field realizes all
possible
evolutions at the same time
in a way each evolution describes a
scenario
and in some of these scenarios the
electrons will interact
with the photon field
[Music]
in this scenario for example the
electron emits a virtual
photon at a certain instant which
carries away
part of its momentum and the virtual
photon is absorbed a little later
by the other electron
[Music]
in this other scenario the electrons
exchange this time
two photons
[Music]
or again in this third more complex
scenario
the electron emits a virtual photon
which is converted into a pair of
virtual electron and positron
that inhalate together into a virtual
photon
which finally ends up absorbed by the
second electron
by exchanging part of their momentum
carried by virtual particles
the two electrons will in some scenarios
get closer
and in others get further apart
now consider the following analogy on a
guitar a
string can vibrate with different
frequencies each of which corresponds to
a pure
sound but when we pluck the string
it starts to vibrate in a superposition
of all these frequencies with more or
less amplitude
and the synthesis of all these pure
sounds together with different
amplitudes
is what makes the total sound produced
by the string
similarly a quantum field evolves
according to every possible scenario
with more or less amplitude and it is
the synthesis of all these scenarios
together
that describe the real evolution of the
physical system
in particular in our example when we add
up all these possibilities
we observe that overall our two
electrons are more and more deflected
they feel a force repelling them because
of the exchanges of virtual photons
this is the electromagnetic force
and if instead we had started with an
electron and a positron
of opposite charge the amplitudes of the
different scenarios would have been
different
resulting this time in an overall
attraction force
[Music]
by allowing particles to interact and
exchange momentum
quantum field theory explains how forces
arise from simple symmetries
the symmetries of the fields which make
up our universe
to conclude quantum field theory is a
mathematical recipe
for building a model universe we start
with an empty space-time
which we fill with quantum fields that
satisfy the symmetries
of special relativity quantum field
theory thus makes it possible to
construct a quantum description of our
universe which satisfies the constraints
imposed by relativity by allowing fields
to interact with each other
this theory makes it possible to predict
with astounding precision
the phenomena that govern our universe
according to quantum field theory the
evolution of our universe is described
as the synthesis of
all possible scenarios at the
microscopic scale
that being said this description remains
incomplete
as even though it satisfies special
relativity quantum field theory cannot
be unified
with general relativity which describes
gravitation by the curvature of
space-time
some results of the theory can already
be calculated in curved space times
such as the prediction that black holes
evaporate over time
however scientists are still looking for
a unified theory
that would explain microscopically why
space-time gets curved
and would reconcile the infinitely large
with the infinitely small
gravity with quantum a theory
of everything
[Music]
you